greets everyone I'm Alana and welcome to
my channel I just got home from the gym
so I don't look great but it's fine
today I just really wanted to make a
video to talk about tell him for anyone
who doesn't already know they announced
that they are laying off or have already
laid off all of that stuff but 25 people
who are there just to finish existing
projects which basically means they are
finishing the Minecraft story thing for
Netflix and my assumption there is that
they are legally required to they're
just doing that so that they don't get
sued by Netflix outside of that though
this video is completely shutting down
and they announced that they are not
going to be finishing the Walking Dead
or the wolf among us - or any of the
other projects that they had announced
so first of all I want to say this sucks
of course it really sucks for everyone
involved it sucks for the gamers who've
been invested in Telltale's games for a
long time people got very attached to
tell tales various projects and I think
a lot of gamers feel richer for telltale
having existed but this video isn't
about that the telltale just kept
screwing up the studio closure was
inevitable because of the way they
treated projects and because of the way
they treated individual projects they
treated their stuff like crap and I have
known that for a long time I've worked
in the games industry for seven years
over seven years now and I've known a
lot of people who want to tell tales
there are people who've spoken on record
about a lot of this stuff that they had
their staff working for a hundred hours
a week
or that they would hire people to work
on projects to have them work very very
quickly to have this insane turnaround
that they had at the episodes and then
fire them as soon as the thing had
shipped one tweet hit me really hard and
paraphrasing but it said something along
the lines of no matter how many late
nights I put in on how many
I was away from family I put in to
working at telltale I still got laid off
and for telltale this was used in the
making this was bad management we've
heard stories about Telltale's terrible
management for a long time since even
before the walking dead those stories
have been out there that they would
halfway through an episode make people
reanimate or rewrite or completely
redraft plot even though all of those
people would be like this isn't possible
we can't do this
they'd have to do it somehow they would
create hours where humans generally need
to sleep just to make an episode of a
telltale game but I think there was a
formula that could have been fantastic
that ended up being you know something
was didn't really feel like they
mattered because we always ended in the
same place engines full of bugs stories
with plot holes and big question marks
and I think that that that showed
because you can't just throw a bunch of
game devs into a room and give them a
very strict timeline and expect them to
come out with something and that's
something I always thought was very
interesting when episodes were coming
out if the date hadn't been announced
yet and the public was mad it's because
telltale didn't have a date until they
had one everything they did was just
worked on tirelessly by so many people
up until the very end where they were
like okay we have to get rid of it let's
send a code out you know way that even
while I was playing those games even
while I was reviewing those episodes
it felt exploitative telltale exploited
people a lot and that meant the quality
of the things went great which meant
that the cycle persisted which meant
that they just kept hiring people over
and over again and then firing them over
and over again just to churn out more
content that is nobody's dreamed of
walking around games is fantastic and I
am blessed to be able to do it but
walking tirelessly on something for a
corporation with little creative control
because of the management at telltale
was also reportedly just very
controlling and
never attic that's nobody's dreams so
tonight telltale announced that they had
a number of companies who showed
interest in helping them finish the
walking dead let me see if I can find
the actual wedding here hi everyone we
have a walking dead update for you
multiple potential partners have stepped
forward to express interest in helping
to see the war in helping to see the
final season through to completion while
we can't make any promises today we are
actively working towards a solution that
will allow episodes 3 & 4 to be
completed and released in some form in
the meantime episode 2 will release
tomorrow across all platforms as planned
we hope to have answers via other
questions soon so they announced it and
a lot of responses to the tweet
initially I don't think it's quite this
way now overwhelmingly positive people
was so happy because they paid for the
season pause and they wanted to get
their episodes and I almost feel like
I'm uh like an outlier here if you paid
for a season pause I completely
understand why you would be pissed off
if you aren't getting the product
frankly I would say you should literally
never pay for a season pause
don't pre-order don't pay the season
passes the games industry can even
exploit game as a lot of times but I get
it you paid for a product I do think
that you deserve that product I think
that it's probably a legal issue however
priorities are an issue yeah I really
like the Walking Dead and I frankly
don't want them to finish it because
everyone who got laid off all 250 people
didn't get severance packages and that
is hard for me to think about that 250
people just walked in to walk one day
and they'd already put all those hours
in because we know that telltale has a
really bad crunch system they've already
just given this company their blood
sweat and tears and
walk in one day and just don't have jobs
anymore and don't have any financial
security it's not like any of them were
getting paid incredibly well in the
first place because this company was
irresponsible with those people who
didn't treat them like people and it's
not just the 250 of them either it's
their families it's their children it's
dear God the amount of them that live in
San Francisco which is an impossibly
expensive city to live in trust me
part of the reason why I left and to get
that tweet from Telltale saying you know
we're trying really hard people are
interested in investing which I'm really
hard to finish the walking dead just
makes me want to say do not finish it
because knowing you
what finishing it means is hiring more
people as contractors walking them to
the bone and then laying them off it's a
system that we know is exploitative and
the most important thing right now for
them as a company should be figuring out
how to give those employees who were
laid off the severance packages I don't
care enough about Clementine for that to
outweigh how much I care for the humans
who worked on those games who put their
blood sweat and tears into getting
anything out on time under a absurd
amount of pressure you just lost all of
that and and had it all rendered useless
even to going to finish the season would
feel just almost disrespectful to
everyone who got laid off like I just
don't see how I could finish that season
and feel okay with it you know we need
context of it but if any of the higher
powers of telltale were watching I would
just say don't finish the Walking Dead
don't let the end of the legacy of
telltale who did produce things that
people love and who did give some people
their first jobs in the industry you
know giving them the ability to work
elsewhere hopefully don't focus
on releasing the final episodes of the
[__] thing that some people paid $20
for which I understand can feel like a
lot of money depending on your financial
situation but ultimately it's very
little compared to the people who just
lost everything but really I would I
would say don't finish the Walking Dead
help those people bust you legally owe
them severance packages and if they
don't get them it affects their entire
families and again just renders all of
the overtime and the high stress
environments and the anxiety that people
have been very open about getting from
walking at telltale completely useless
it was never good but if if they don't
get severance it's completely useless it
just sucks so to leave on a positive
note one telethon finish the Walking
Dead give these people what they need
instead please and then you can finish
the Walking Dead and wrap up the season
for all the fans who can and then
secondly I didn't want to say how
awesome it has been to see so much of
the games industry publicly just sort of
supporting each other saying like this
this place is hiring Ubisoft is having
an event for telltale employees who got
laid off it's just that has been really
nice to see oh
my light just went out all right friends
I'm Ilana did not expect to make this
video today but here we are I will see
you guys next time bye